[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec marc antoine pérouse de
montclos auteur du livre une guerre
perdue aux éditions jean claude lattès à
paraître ce mercredi directeur de
recherche également à l'institut de
recherche pour le développement bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
mériadec raffray secrétaire général de
l'association des journalistes
spécialisés défense auteur de touaregs
la révolte des hommes bleus aux éditions
economica bonsoir impossible si d'être
là alors on est venu et le mettront qui
a répondu à une partie à des questions
qui se posaient avant même ce sauvés
puisque on l'a entendu il annonce ce
soir donc le renforcement de la
coopération française hausse elle envoie
même de 220 soldats supplémentaires
c'est une surprise pour vous on va
commencer par vous marc antoine pérouse
de montclos est bien vrai qu'on
n'attendait pas une révolution de ce
sommet qui rappelez-vous faisait suite
aussi à cet accident d'hélicoptère
autour duquel on avait perdu 13 soldats
et qui seront effectivement avec un
sentiment de monter de rejet de la
présence militaire française je suis pas
sûr que ce sommet va désamorcer cette ce
rejet de la présence militaire française
encore faudrait-il que les présidents
des pays du g5 sahel effectivement fasse
des déclarations claires dans leurs
capitales et pas seulement à pau donc à
voir en sachant que cette ce sentiment
en fait traduit deux choses d'une part
c'est extrêmement humiliant pour
beaucoup d'africains de voir que c'est
l'ancienne puissance coloniale qui doit
se substituer à des armes est
défaillante est compris dans des pays
comme le burkina qui avait une espèce de
tradition révolutionnaire anti
impérialiste et puis d'autre part ça
exprime la frustration ça fait
maintenant 70 la france s'est engagée
d'abord au mali puis dans les pays
voisins
ces temps de réflexion pourquoi les
groupes jihadistes sont toujours
présents le mali toujours coupée en deux
donc il ya une espèce de frustration qui
en fait est à la mesure de l'enlisement
des troupes françaises dans la région
médiathèque raffray peut-être pas une
une révolution il n'empêche emmanuel
macron clairement avait dit avant ce
sommet soit il notre présence
ont ils besoin de nous je veux des
réponses claires et assumé sur ces
questions manifestement il ya répondu
puisque il dit oui il réaffirme cette
eau des puissances française pardon cet
engagement français sur place
bon c'est pas une surprise chacun savait
bien que la france n'allait pas se
désengager du sel parce que tout
simplement c'est impossible
jouer simplement rebondir sur les propos
de mon voisin vous le dirai pourquoi
c'est impossible parce que les étalons
alors oui alors ok je réponds de
vitrification s'intéressant
effectivement les américains sont en
train entre quelque sorte de nous lâcher
au sel reste une surprise on peut en
discuter
les américains en fait appuyé les
français en matière de logistique
ils ont des gros porteurs qui permettent
de faire des manoeuvres aériennes de
transport compliqué ils ont des avions
qui ravitaille nos chasseurs qui sont en
permanence en l'air ils ont surtout
toute une panoplie de moyens qui leur
permettent de faire du renseignement et
qui viennent alimenter nos propres
capteurs qui sont efficacement droits
limités et donc effectivement si les
américains partent c'est un vrai sujet
sur lequel planche actuellement l'elysée
les états majors donc c'est impossible
de partir seul alors pourquoi c'est
impossible de partir écouter on peut
prendre une analogie qui est récente en
2014 il ya ce qu'on appelle d'âge qui
naît en irak sur les ruines de l'irak
ont quitté les américains en 2011
et voilà ici en fait on part aujourd'hui
c'est globalement ce qui se passera à la
vitesse grand v on le voit aujourd'hui
les garnisons nigérienne les garnisons
maliennes sont attaqués en permanence
évidemment parce que l'ennemi ne veut
absolument pas que les armées africaines
prennent le lead prennent l'ascendant et
en particulier ne veulent surtout pas de
cette force du g5 sahel qui est en
capacité d'aller de part et d'autre et
les frontières et donc de porter le fer
dans le seul le principal atout de cette
série djihadistes à savoir se jouer des
frontières pour ne pas prêter flanc en
fait aux armées conventionnelles de la
france et est du mali
et donc si on part demain tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que c'est le
chaos je vous rappelle qu'en 2013 en
janvier enfin à l'été 2013 moi j'étais
du côté de abidjan et je le mets les
ministres nous disait en off nous avions
très peur en janvier 2013 que les
djihadistes qui descendait du nord vers
bamako et que l'opération serval arrête
en janvier 2013 ne continue ensuite
jusqu'à la mer voilà un témoignage
autres autres autre élément pour aller
dans ce sens aujourd'hui on voit bien
que cette ce cancer djihadistes les
métastases djihadistes qui gangrènent
aujourd'hui le sel s'étendent au bénin
où la vue en mai avec l'opération font
délivrer nos otages qui avait été pris
dans les forêts du nord du bénin
plus tôt en 2016 à grand bassam qui est
institué dans le sud d'abidjan il ya eu
un attentat terroriste inédit le sénégal
a un sujet bref l'ensemble de la région
aujourd'hui gangrené par le djihadisme
terroriste marc antoine adam enclos moi
c'est le récit dominons effectivement
dit que si la france n'était pas
intervenu en 2013 les djihadistes venus
du nord qui étaient surtout des touareg
à l'époque qui seront détestés à bamako
une ville d'un million d'habitants est
la plus grosse ville au nord en fait 100
milles au mieux avec tombouctou que
cette déferlante allait s'emparer du
pouvoir à bamako
il ya des discours officiels et puis on
va ni vous ni moi allons refaire
l'histoire
il faut rappeler que des chaussées
emparé de mossoul en irak parce qu'ils
avaient soutient la population locale
c'était absolument pas le cas à bamako
donc le scénario qui est présenté comme
une évidence par l'elysée sur laquelle
sans nous finalement le mali serait
devenu un ca et listant bon
ça mérite d'être discutée qu'on soit
dans une situation de chaos si l'armée
française se retire il y aura des
situations de troupes dans le nord comme
il y en avait en 2012 mais encore une
fois pour beaucoup de maliens notamment
à bamako la situation s'est pas
forcément beaucoup améliorée parce que
la présence de l'état est toujours très
très très très faible est ce que
vraiment il s'agit toujours de groupes
djihadistes à dire qu'en fait on voit
s'entremêler énormément de conflit que
l'on qualifie de terroristes de
jihadistes dans certains cercles les
officiels lui qui en fait font
apparaître ou du banditisme armé qui
nécessite la plus tôt des opérations de
police des conflits de bétail des
conflits d'accès aux ressources à la
terre etc
tout ça est extrêmement complexe et
c'est pour ça que je dis dans mon livre
que finalement on a confié à l'armée
française une espèce de mission
impossible
oui et je m'étonne un peu qu'on discute
aujourd'hui de savoir s'il faut partir
ou pas parce qu'un jour il faudra bien
partir quand même donc la fille question
du désengagement
c'est plutôt de savoir quand et comment
à mon avis mais on lui a confié
finalement la mission qui consisterait
en fait à construire des états au sel
parce que là il ya aussi un consensus
pour dire que le fond du problème que le
djihadisme c'est finalement le symptôme
d'état fait avec le fond du problème il
est politique et que la solution est
entre les mains des africains et pas de
l'elysée donc tant que vous avez des
armées nationales qui commettent des
exactions qui rackettent les populations
qui du coup deviennent très impopulaire
qui commettent des exactions des
exécutions extrajudiciaires qui pousse
du coup les survivants dans les bras des
djihadistes pourraient chercher
protection ou bien de tous les groupes
armés de la zone un certain qualifié de
djihadiste d'autres de simplement de
bandes armées
effectivement on a un vrai problème sur
le type de réponse militaire qui est
actuellement engagée par les armées
africaines et ses armées africaines et
c'est aussi un risque que je pointe
comme est donc des exactions qui vont
peut-être un jour rejaillir directement
sur l'armée française qui est équipé
forme aussi une partie de ses armées
africaines donc on a un vrai risque là y
compris et je tiens quand même à leur
rappeler c'est qu'aucun de ces groupes
que l'on combat au sahel n'a jamais
commis d'attentats terroristes en europe
ou en amérique ne reconnais pas du tout
dans la même rue lock on n'est pas
encore donc on eût dit il faut
intervenir parce que peut-être qu'un
jour il pourrait monter des attaques
outre-mer s'aggraver
pour eux comme c'est à dire qu il faut
voir dans quelle mesure la prophétie
n'est pas auto réalisatrices kadiri
fictivement à force de combattre ces
groupes qui dit qu'un jour ils vont pas
mobiliser les diasporas africaines en
europe pour commettre des attentats à
voir mais en attendant je rappelle que
c'est un scénario pitié pour les hanter
oui c'est un scénario fiction alors
c'est ce qui serait bien c'est bon tu
sais ce qui s'est passé depuis quelques
années avec la syrie et les bancs et les
banlieues françaises sur ce point de vue
c'est une guerre préventive
j'étais comme ça dont elle est présente
je signale qu'il ya des situations de
chaos terrible dans le sud du soudan
dans l'est de la rdc en somalie on y
envoie pas 5000 soldats dans ces tracés
sont pas les mêmes non pas le dire il
n'ya pas d'hypocrisie sur le pour le
compteur des siens choses très chaud son
duo nantais comme si on est là pour
stabiliser d étain et les aider à se
reconstruire
très bien mais c'est aussi beaucoup la
mission des nations unies et pourquoi
faire intervenir la france or ce qui est
présenté régulièrement c'est que si on
ne fait rien on a respectivement une
déferlante djihadistes à la fois sur
bamako et pourquoi pas de nouveau demain
sur paris alors reprenons le scénario il
est deuxième chose on ira quand vous
irez vous les français ne voulaient pas
y aller
les politiques feraient des cas doit
nicolas sarkozy et était évidemment
contre une nouvelle intervention
ce sont les événements qui ont précipité
la france au sahel
aucun expert ne souhaitais je vous
rappelle qu'on sortait d'aghanistan on
disait après l'afghanistan plus aucun
soldat au sol nofoot underground c'était
l'expression américaine qu'on aime bien
on aime bien recyclés donc en fait la
france est allée contre son gré au mali
effectivement les aujourd'hui les
raisons pour lesquelles la france y
reste et hyper je vous rappelle que la
france est le seul pays au monde à
accepter que ces soldats meurent au mali
pour la sécurité est effectivement pour
les buts de guerre qui sont affirmés à
savoir éviter qu'il se crée un no man's
land jihadistes dans ces zones dont je
vous rappelle la l'immensité le repos
lol c'est l'europe en quelque sorte
deuxièmement permettre aux africains un
jour de prendre à leur compte cette
menace aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas encore
traitées par eux mêmes ça ce sont les
deux les deux phénomènes et évidemment
par ricochet c'est de permettre à ces
états de
se stabilise et de se reconstruire et ça
effectivement c'est une autre guerre il
faut savoir de quelle guerre on parle si
on parlait à la guerre militaire ça
c'est cette mission est ensuite
effectivement il ya d'autres guerres qui
viennent se greffer sur cette opération
et qui évidemment rendre complexe
l'équation et cc autre guerre politique
de développement économique culturel
mêmes qui aujourd'hui effectivement sont
à l'arrêt et qui rendent la situation
des militaires complexes avant poursuit
pardonnez moi le débat je vous propose
d'écouter le général train quant à eux
qui étaient sur ce plateau de 26
novembre qui s'exprime justement lui
aussi en faveur de cette présence
militaire française et internationale
sur place
il faut continuer à combattre ces
groupes djihadistes parce que sinon ils
installent un état islamiste dans la
région et je rappelle que l'état
islamiste n'est pas vraiment la solution
qui a été choisie ni par le mali ni par
le burkina faso ni par le niger ni par
le tchad elle depuis cinq ans tout le
monde attend que le mali l'accord
d'alger par exemple soit appliqué
l'accord d'alger n'est pas appliquée
vivez donc donc les populations
évidemment s'impatiente du fait que les
accords ne sont pas appliquées une
solution n'est pas trouvée et que des
forces sont obligés d'être présente
forces étrangères comme la force barkat
forces françaises où la minus ma force
de l'onu qui est présente également avec
douze mille hommes sur la région est
sauf qu'on n'est pas un petit peu seul
là si les états unis engagent alors
emmanuel macron a vu j'appelle tous les
pays qui veulent nous rejoindre mon sauf
qui a pas beaucoup de réponses pour
l'instant que peut faire la france seule
avec 220 soldats annoncé en plus ce soir
marche antoine est justement le fait
qu'on soit seul du côté des occidentaux
à intervenir des montres qui est
peut-être pas la même analyse qui fait
chez nos alliés européens d'abord y
compris d'ailleurs les états unis
puisque rappelez vous quand on est
intervenue en janvier 2013 les plans
dans vous le qui consistait à envoyer
des soldats au sol qui était pas du tout
ce qu'on avait en décembre 2
douze avaient été disons de manière un
petit peu abrupte présentés comme de la
merde je cite susan rice qui était
l'ambassadrice des états unis à l'époque
aux nations unies et qui ne croyait pas
du tout à la capacité de la france en
tant qu'ancienne puissance coloniale à
rétablir la souveraineté du mali et à
stabiliser la région rebelle à vue les
uns s'étaient vus résultats
sept ans après on voit le résultat
effectivement le mali n'a toujours pas
retrouvé sa souveraineté sur notre
groupe rebelle est toujours qu'ils
perçoivent les impôts à la place de
l'état dans le nord les groupes
jihadistes n'ont pas désarmé par exemple
c'est donc guillaume il faut soit réussi
à terminer là dessus c'est que nos
alliés européens n'avaient pas la même
vision non plus que nous de l'extension
de cette menace et du son caractère
global contrairement à ce qui se passe
encore une fois avec l'état islamique en
irak et en syrie où là il y en a une
vraie menace globale avec des
djihadistes qui viennent d'outre-mer
c'est pas le cas il n'y a pas de
financement d'armes ou de djihadistes
qui viennent d'outre-mer pour aller
soutenir la katiba du macina donc les
dynamiques sont d'abord locale et
excusez-moi si les allemands ou les
britanniques étaient vraiment convaincu
que si on ne fait rien dans la zone
demain ils auront un attentat à londres
à berlin joue garanties qui seraient
davantage à nos côtés donc voilà non ce
discours c'est un discours 2011 l'elysée
d'abord de hollande puis de macron mais
il faut le savoir tout le monde ne
partage pas ce point de vue sur
l'ampleur et la réalité de la globalité
de cette menace est encore une fois on
est dans une guerre préventive de ce
point de vue il n'y a pas encore eu
d'attac peut-être tir lara bien n'a pas
eu alors si on doit intervenir partout
dans le monde à chaque fois en disant
tiens il pourrait peut-être un jour y
avoir des répercussions sur notre pays
la séquence d'intro dise ce qu'on dit et
ce qu'a dit le susan rice et que vous
avez cités aujourd'hui les plans
d'intervention de l'opération services
ont fini dans les écoles de guerre
américaine donc qu'ils y croyaient pas
on l'a fait et avec des moyens qui sont
infinies le atik infiniment bout
beaucoup plus réduit que coller leur ses
premières choses deuxième chose sur le
djihadisme évidemment qu'ils allaient
financement aujourd'hui deux de ces
katiba qui sont des financements
internationaux
l'argent des ong dia djihadistes du
golfe arrive en flo a dans cette région
je suis content l'asnl a en revanche là
où je suis d'accord avec là où je suis
d'accord c'est qu'il n'y a pas de traces
effectivement de deux traçable évidente
de terroristes qui viendraient de la
zone de neige dont on reste
effectivement dans un djihad en quelque
sorte régionales bon ensuite la france
martèle des points oui la france ne
dépend aujourd'hui les terroristes
avaient l'habitude d'attaquer en h'cup
aujourd'hui sont en moto parce que il y
en a plus on estime aujourd'hui que
barkan depuis peu près cet été à ali
milliers 150-200 de son djihadistes donc
ces voix là on fait le job
troisièmement les chefs qui sont
essentiellement arabes pour le coup et
qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas forcément
originaire de deux des régions qu'on se
bat aujourd'hui sont éliminés les uns
près des autres par par les forces
spéciales les derniers en date on peut
les citer c'est le numéro 2 par exemple
du gspm qui est un groupe qui se situe
au nord du mali il y en a un autre qui
s'appelle l'émir de tombouctou qui se
situe à l'ouest donc les résultats sont
là évidemment ce problème quand je
disais tout à l'heure a commencé à la
fin des années au début des années 60 un
début des années 60 c'est juste un essai
l'indépendance du mali et à ce moment là
les anciens esclaves prennent leur
revanche sur leur seigneur c'est à dire
les gens du sud plutôt de pau noah
prennent leur revanche sur ce qui
historiquement les avait mis en
esclavage c'est dans les touareg et
depuis ce temps là on a d un
enchaînement de deux comment dirais-je
de révolte de rêve de révolte de
rébellion qui ont conduit au début des
années 2000 à la fin des années 2000
ah au fait que ce que le nord tout le
nord du mali deviennent hors de contrôle
un espèce de far west dans lequel sont
fins et les dj alice donc personne ne
prétend qu'on va régler le problème
même en ces temps ça me paraît assez
évident mériadec raffray cela dit pour
vous comment vous expliquez vous avez
l'air tellement convaincus de ce bien
fondé de la présence française sur place
ce fort sentiment anti français
d'ailleurs inquiet cité ce soir par le
président français lui-même emmanuel
macron qui dénonce d'ailleurs des bons
ses pattes qui parle des puissances
étrangères pour discréditer un la france
pour alimenter ce discours anti
français il existe on l'a vu d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau
mais des observateurs qui disait la
france n'est là que pour l'uranium les
ca service à cet enfant de cet enfant là
on est d'accord on plaide pour une fois
on est d'accord là où je suis d'accord
avec mon voisin c'est qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que les
présidents africains et africaines sont
elles mêmes confrontés un certain nombre
de problèmes qui sont des problèmes qui
sont liés aux eaux théréau à leur
territoire c'est les problèmes de
politiques des problèmes d'équilibré
sociaux des problèmes de comment
dirais-je de conflits ethniques des
problèmes religieux qui sont des
problèmes auxquels évidemment ils
doivent répondre
indépendamment ou en plus ou à côté ou
simultanément du fait qu'ils ont besoin
de barkan pour ne pas s'écrouler
complètement face à la menace est celle
là où on arrive parfois à des
distorsions discours j'ajoute quand même
pour être tout à fait complet qu'un
certain nombre de quelques quelques
responsables je citerai pas les noms sur
ce plateau sont connus pour des
accointances avec des groupes qui font
des trafics voire même qui sont en lien
eux-mêmes avec des djihadistes et qu'ils
ont évidemment aucun intérêt ce que la
sécurité revienne vous touillez ça et ça
donne le sentiment anti français
alors j'ai avant vous faire réagir
marc-antoine de montage on écoute le
sentiment de la classe politique
française qui est également comme vous
sur ce plateau divisés sur ce sujet le
mali sera t'il l'afghanistan de la
france sept ans après le début de son
intervention militaire va-t-elle
comprendre que la seule riposte armée
est une impasse son passé colonial et
les survivance de la françafrique
permettent d'en douter
la france a eu un rôle au mali mais n'a
pas vocation à rester indéfiniment ayons
un débat serein sur le sens et l'utilité
de notre présence militaire au mali et
préparons intelligemment les conditions
du départ futur de nos troupes
aujourd'hui à bamako une marche contre
la france où emmanuel macron est
représentée en hitler et les drapeaux
français sont brûlés un des défis au
mali c'est précisément le fait que
barkan est une opération militaire sans
objectif politique identifier les bases
de l'intervention française sont
confuses
en partant maintenant on créerait un
chaos au moins aussi grand que celui
qu'on prétend juger
et nous n'avons pas vocation à rester là
éternellement sur le continent nous ne
sommes pas le gendarme de l'afrique
on s'aime pas le gendarme de l'afrique
objectif politique non identifié vous
êtes d'accord marc-antoine de montclos
avec cette analyse très à gauche en tout
cas non identifiés ou non dit parce
qu'il faut voir qu'au nom de la lutte
contre le terrorisme la présence
militaire française sert en fait à
consolider des régimes qui sont souvent
très corrompu et parfois même très
autoritaire et que donc la présence
militaire française en fête sert
d'assurance vie à ces gouvernements y
compris contre le risque de coup d'état
par leurs propres forces de sécurité
parce que j'ai eu des mutineries et puis
toute une tradition de coup d'état dans
la zone
on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec le dévoilement
officiel d'opérations barkan dont
l'objectif a priori le mandat et lutter
contre ce que les militaires appellent
les groupes armés terroristes mais qui
finalement quelque chose qui peut
suivant le temps variés et une
dénomination qui peut recouvrir beaucoup
de choses mais là encore l'année
dernière en fait l'opération barkan a
servi à rembourser des colonnes de
rebelles qui venaient de libye qui
n'était pas du tout réaliste qui
attaquait en fait le président deby qui
est faut-il le rappeler au pouvoir
n'djamena depuis 1990 a lui-même étant
arrivée par un coup de force
donc évidemment pour ces régimes la la
lutte contre le terrorisme
et puis insister sur la dimension
globale de la menace si on fait rien et
c'est ça va empirer et puis ça va
devenir le sae l'instant c'est une
véritable aubaine
ça leur permet de se racheter sur la
scène internationale la plus de
critiques contre les violations des
droits de l'homme
ça leur permet d'obtenir des
financements et une aide au
développement
ça permet que la france finance des fins
de mois des salaires de la fonction
publique au tchad ce que peu de gens le
savent
j'ai écrit ces publics ces publics mais
c'est aberrant que pour moi ce n'est pas
un problème voyez as well as non parce
que voilà on peut aussi on débarque
justement que l'on paie que l'on paye
les salaires de la fonction publique
sans même poser des questions sur la
destination de la rente pétrolière au
tchad qui n'est d'ailleurs même pas
exploité par les français parce que le
roman on est d'accord avec mathias et
ans n'est pas intervenu pour mettre la
main sur des intérêts économiques
c'est une idée très tôt nassau merrion
clair les marchés sahélien en tout cas
de cette zone du sahel ce qu'on fait le
sahel c'est beaucoup plus vaste en
prêtant en france mais ces marchés là
sont trop limitées chiens pour qu'ils
aient la moindre impact sur notre
balance commerciale
le seul intérêt stratégique c'est au
niger avec l'uranium dans le nord et
dans ce cas là c'est qu'il ya une
sérieuse erreur de gps en 2013 parce
qu'on est intervenu au mali et au niger
dont il ya eu apparemment et enfin même
au niger les la france n'est pas en
pointe dans le ja rayonnant que sont les
centres aérés les nuls durant leurs
adversaires et d'humanisme n'est pas non
plus pas pour ça qu'on est intervenue
mais enfin on peut aussi choisir de f1
ouais on peut aussi choisir le modèle
kadhafi c'est à dire qu'on renverse et
dictateurs qui on savoure sans doute et
vers le défaut mais qui sont aussi
capables de maintenir un semblant
d'ordre qui permet de ne pas connaître
le cas aujourd'hui donc merci en tout
cas messieurs marc antoine pérouse de
montclos mairie avec à voir après
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france après d'ailleurs ces annonces des
manuels mettront ce soir de renforcement
de la coopération de la france on sait